my tick tock game got stronger check out
my videos but we're actually going to
watch other people's videos be whoa
you are at risk of type 2 diabetes i
think it possibly might be a yeast
infection yeast infection imagine that's
how i delivered news to my patients the
best treatment option is probably fungal
cream and bunker cream for what for the
yeast infection i mean we could just
give a single pill here i don't know
what's happening but it is good musical
theater what's the musical theater
diagnosis you could give a patient
pneumonia
benign prostatic hyperplasia
knock knock big house what's up big dog
so look the abdominal pain you came in
with little sus right so we sent you
down for the scans right and i mean the
scans came back and they're certainly
not busting
i'm not gonna lie i've seen residents
talk like this amongst each other and i
kind of laugh because i'm getting too
old for it bussing yeah new cap like
high key big yikes
dude i don't know what you're saying all
right bet big facts uh but no we're
gonna get you down to the or big facts
no printer even on like conversations
with like patients it doesn't get this
crazy i'm doing dpr2 oh she's doing
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions
oh how did she know that's so good she's
watching the good content it doesn't
work on ipads fantastic
don't use q-tips in your ears
because you push the earwax further back
and then i'm gonna have to operate on
you like i did jen selter check out my
tic-tac of me doing so two tips just
push all the earwax in deeper right i
mean yeah but what else am i supposed to
do well you could let me put this straw
of hydrogen peroxide in it
why it melts it and then allows it to
naturally come out or sometimes you
could just
shoot a little soapy water in there or
something and clean it out because it'll
actually loosen up the ear wax and clean
out your ear
no this is the weirdest thing ever
you don't actually have to put the straw
in your head you just let the fluid leak
out into your ear when i was a kid i
discovered this crazy talent and i was
examined by doctors they said it was
almost superhuman-like when i drink a
glass of water and i move my lips up and
down i can heat it up into water beta
what no
i don't believe that you can't trust
anything you see online unless it's
happening directly in front of me and i
know his name is not david blaine or
he's a famous magician water vapor like
that's boiling he boils it
oh my god no i'm hopeful that that is
just an x-ray of a buzz lightyear behind
a person because inside of a person
it has edges his his his wings
to infinity and beyond oh
oh my god what is happening here is this
acupuncture this feels largely
unnecessary no you can't put the thing
on his head when you can't do that
don't do it oh man that doesn't look
comfortable
the problem with this is like it's going
through the muscles so if you're trying
to make some kind of facial expression
imagine like you're trying to move and
all the needles
if you put two arms up
then put one arm down
and then push that arm backwards twice
that arm will become much longer than
the other arm
no it didn't work
you can't see it but i promise you it
doesn't work unless you just like
loosened it up or the other arm got
tired or something i don't know this is
medical misinformation if you pinch your
arm 10 times
close your eyes and then touch your
elbow
you won't feel anything
oh
these are i don't understand one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
i still feel everything i feel my hand
it doesn't even make sense the body's
quite capable of feeling pinches and
touches
before kita
sad
after
no keto is not a miracle potion yes it
does help people get some short-term
weight loss some people really love it
but medically it's not miraculous as
people say all right let's just talk
about it who's the most important organ
it's definitely me because it's the
brain we did the pull the brain
everything to do y'all can't think for
yourselves that's true hey if i didn't
pump blood to you you wouldn't be able
to function though but i have that
blood though but you wouldn't be able to
tell me to punt blood if i didn't pump
blood to you yeah but that's like the
chicken before the egg without the brain
the heart's not pumping and when the
heart pumps the brain can continue to
function but the brain needs to be there
to start the process first yes in trauma
protocol we try and save the lungs and
the heart without the brain nothing's a
cooking i like the brain i think the
brain is magical i think it's beautiful
i think it's a fun organ i like to touch
it not like while it's in people's heads
but like in cadavers when you're
learning about you've been using your
ears wrong right and left actually have
different functions no they don't if
you're somewhere loud and trying to hear
what someone is saying you're more
likely to succeed uh no all of this is
nonsense this is i
cool
that looks
like a ganglion cyst and i have drained
those i've also taken those out
oh
don't do that
fair
is that dog's name bear
he's literally slapping me with his
tongue
do you think he's hyper metal
oh i thought it's so mean just standing
there like waiting for someone to take
it off my face
oh baby
it's gonna poop or fart
it's a farty baby we do that to babies
it looks like torture but babies
actually really like it bend over
psychiatrist
uh doctor there's a patient out here
saying he's turning invisible uh tell
him i can't see him now
um he also said he's shrinking
well he's going to have to be a little
patient
that's really good it's a little patient
oh why is this dog so scared of the nail
clippers though oh no puppy no
that must mean they did it wrong last
time because it's not supposed to hurt
when i do it to bear he doesn't even
care he's just like dude i feel so so
nauseous right smelling this oh alcohol
gross
is this rubbing alcohol still feel
nauseous actually no
thanks
throw up uh
start humming
[Music]
i don't have to throw up anymore
my nose won't stop running easy trick to
clear sinuses is hold your tongue to the
roof of your mouth and then press your
thumb to your forehead you know too much
dude you don't know too much because all
of that is fake news i'm sorry you had a
good one with the ears not a good one
here unfortunately you've uh tested
positive for a plethora what diseases oh
my god am i going to die firstly you
have mononycola jokage maleonicola
college a little mononucleosis meaning
tits what is that a nipple issue
meningitis rabbis
rabies
diaria yaria give me that you've been
mispronouncing all of these the way you
say these differentiates on where you
went to medical school rabies not rabbis
mononucleosis not mono
are you even a doctor that's
confidential it's not confidential you
could look that up i am never donating
blood again ever the very second you
walk in the door question after question
where did you get it why is it in a
bucket do you want a monster don't you
that is not where i thought that would
go yeah donate blood out in a bucket
that's not how it works no that's
sometimes when a woman's appendix burst
they ignore it because it's the same as
a parry crap well they don't ignore it
doctors sometimes ignore it because they
think it's like a period cramp and they
just blame it on the menstrual cycle and
that's horribly wrong some convicts
women are aliens the pain tolerance they
know everything they know when you're
lying high emotional intelligence and
being disbelieved by the medical system
this is facts it actually does happen
quite often put a finger down if one day
you woke up with what you thought was a
late season flu and then a couple hours
later you developed some charlie horses
in your legs but instead of these chili
horses lasting only a couple minutes
they ended up lasting six hours when you
got to the er you didn't look like an
emergent case because you're a healthy
23 year old you got hot and you pulled
some blankets off your legs and your dad
asked you what was on your leg and you
looked down it looked like a giant
bruise and it wasn't there a couple
hours ago so your husband go get the er
doctor and then you don't remember
anything for two weeks and when you woke
up you were missing your entire left leg
and you had a giant scar on your right
arm
what what was the diagnosis looked it up
necrotizing fasciitis brutal brutal
condition terrible story but this is
prime example of ptg post-traumatic
growth sharing a story so others don't
feel alone positivity humor i'm a fan
i'm watching
this tick tock grandma over here has
some medical questions and has some
medical statements are they real are
they not we're going to discuss it here
click here to check that out and while
you do that stay happy and healthy
grandma tick tock grandma jpg